Our next guest is an Atlanta local
who made headlines when he went from rapper to cat trapper.
Sterling Davis operates Trap King Humane Cat Solutions
out of his RV in Atlanta, Georgia.
The organization provides shelter
and other humane medical services for stray cats.
Please welcome to the show with Ross and myself, Sterling.
Hi Sterling.
Hey Drew how you doing?
Hey Ross, how you doing?
How y'all doing?
We're so good and we're so happy to see you today.
Yeah you know we rescue animals as well
we both have rescued animals
so this is so important to both of us.
For starters just thanks for all you do for all these cats.
Thank you,
thank you all for having rescued pets thank you.
Please tell us about your story.
How did you evolve into this magnanimous work that you do?
I always loved animals especially cats
but I was always into music and in-between music tour
I saw an ad I was just trying to find something to do.
I saw an ad to help scoop litter
and I ended up going just to do it for a couple months
until I went back on tour
but I ended up falling in love with it
and I ended up staying.
I had to call my buddies and tell them,
"hey I'm not coming back because I'm rescuing kitties."
And they like what?
(laughs)
I love that you went from rapper to rescuer
now we've rescued so maybe we'll go to rapping next Drew
maybe that's what we should do.
Well, maybe not.
But here's the question
I know that you have some help there in the Atlanta area
with some of your rescue the stuff that you do but
how do you pay for the food or the surgery?
Where does that those funds come from?
Well, I actually believe it or not
and I'm in here right now.
I live out of my RV, my vehicle.
At first I started with the conversion van
and I lived out of that because
there's no way I could afford rent
and cat surgeries at the same time.
So I actually from donations
and actually Atlanta Humane Society
they saw what I was doing and reached out to me
and they started to do a lot of my surgeries for free
because like I said it can get real expensive
paying for surgeries.
And that's one of the reasons why I stay out of a vehicle
'cause rent and cat surgeries
wasn't going to work at the same time.
And just so we can clarify
for anyone who's kind enough to be at home watching
and our VFFs may I make sure I'm getting this right,
you rescue the cats
and then you make sure they get spayed or neutered
and then release them?
Yeah, so TNR, Trap Neuter Return
so it's the humane alternative for death in euthanasia
for stray of feral cats.
Oh gosh!
So catch the cats in humane traps
I take them to Atlanta Humane Society
I get them spayed, neutered, vaccinated
and I return them back to their colony.
So this prevents overpopulation and spreading disease.
A lot of times there may be some cats
that's too friendly to go back outside
they would rather be in a forever that's fur-ever home.
Oh yeah take that pun up.
Okay he's punny.
I'm glad you're so nice
I was worried you'd be a little catty.
(laughs)
Ross loves a pun and I love it when you do it.
I'm blown away by what you do.
I just think this is so incredible
and that you do it by yourself.
It's true and we're not the only ones Ross,
it turns out that the cat food brand Smalls,
which by the way please go on their website
very chic, wonderful company.
They have human grade cat food
and they are donating $5,000 worth
of that high protein human grade cat food
for you and your furry friends.
And they customize the subscriptions
and allow you to have this fresh nutritious cat food
but they'll deliver it right to you as well.
How cool is that?
(claps)
Are you serious?
To me?
Yes.
Thank you all so much.
I'm going to feed a lot of colonies with that
please believe it.
I know how much of your own resources
you pour into these animals so Ross and I
wanna just throw in an extra $3,000
for any other things you might need along the way
and just show our gratitude
for what you're doing in the world.
And you're really an inspiration to us all Sterling.
Yeah, cats what I'm talking about.
(laughs)
Thank you all so much.
That is amazing, really seriously.
Drew I've been a huge fan of yours forever
watch everything you do.
So to be sitting here talking to you about cats
right now is amazing to me thank you.
Ross thank you so much.
This is amazing y'all thank y'all so much.
Please, enough about us thank you.
Yeah, you're the reason we're doing this right now.
So it's all about you Sterling.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)